[Music]
well one of the things that I've always
appreciated about your message and kind
of what you put out to the world is that
you're very much a traditionalist about
the steps and sobriety in a world in
which it seems like every year without
fail somebody comes up with some new
idea that's followed by a lot of think
pieces about how antiquated Alcoholics
Anonymous is and I'm all for new ideas
and kind of spearheading you know
interesting perspectives on sobriety and
recovery but the 12 steps are what got
me sober and G be sober they work
they've worked for countless people that
I know and it almost it almost feels
like you have you're being you're
cutting across culture now and it's it's
sort of a risk to come out and say this
actually works you know and it was so
straightforward in your recovery book
and I really appreciated that thank you
I feel the only way I'd be able to do it
was by speaking from a personal
perspective and I spoke to a lot of
people perspective and acknowledging
that anything that I know thats worth
knowing has been taught to me and I
spoke to a lot of people they've got a
little more time than me and said and
one person in particular that I know guy
who's all for docs you know a nice of
sitting right I'm doing this thing
what do you how do you know how should I
do this and I thought if I if this guy
can like I can get him to say it's all
right then it's all right because he is
you know even in terms of like dancing
around the tradition of anonymity yeah
how is I never say which fellowships if
any I go to that's how I know but it's
almost like a technic it's like a
technicality hmm you know yeah we're
calling it the secret society we all
know what we're talking about here yeah
and and we're in a different world like
I I struggle with this cuz I don't know
where that line is I'm sure I've crossed
it many times only in my own personal
experience not with anybody else's but
still I never know quite where that
demarcation that DMZ exists well for me
like well I've done is I've never self
spoke I've never said cause I've never
said a particular fellowship
name I can't be claiming speak I'm part
of a fellowship 12 tips is applicable to
Clara's alcoholic drag they're either
smokers you know and I've had they're
probably the same as you on the way into
addiction food and sex issues on the way
out of Indian food and sex issues and
and now like them the codependency my
relationships and the 12-step method is
applicable universally so um I don't
debate it because I say like for me like
you I'm grateful to the to the groups
that I belong to in that they've
provided me you know I've saved my life
and without it I wouldn't be I don't
better on my own but what I feel like is
well I feel like it's an amazing
technique and I feel like that there's
as many ways of working it as there are
people working it I think it's robust
enough some of the nice thing about
Shakespeare to have doing I'm developing
a show where I use Shakespearean
monologues to tell a biographical story
I mean I take some or and do a logs I
take an argument between Caliban and
Prospero so this was like my stepdad a
speech of Richard the third that he's
always like to feel ugly a speech from
Hamlet about feeling loss and connection
to comedy um and the guy at this scholar
from Warwick University professor this
guy Tony he said to me Shakespeare is
robust Shakespeare can handle it like
it's like it's not so fragile and
delicate but we have to stage it in this
way you have a say in that way it can
handle it is powerful stuff you know
this is truth it's got truth in it I
feel the same way with the 12 steps that
you know if like if you want to work it
excuse me as an atheist there was a
Buddhist or a Muslim or if you like how
you know it can handle it because it's
obviously universe with predates the
12-step fellowships in some form in
evident form in through the Oxford group
and those first centers and Christian
groups that were using it and I'm gonna
do a dissertation with Rose University
in London to look at the origins of
these ideas and where they are found on
where are they found is there precedent
in Buddhism Hinduism Christian they're
obviously mostly derived from
Christianity and sort of Union
psychology those are those things we
sort of ignore it William James you know
we know about those ideas and Emma Fox
likes of first century Christians or
writers but
I'm interested in whether these ideas
coming from like a proper scholarly
dissertation yeah like legitimate
straight-up academic paper yes we've
done blows in the middle of it I'm in
the middle of a degree religion in
global politics yes because well I like
part-time no and it and even his class
going on in the UK right now I'm trying
to use this as for one of my modules
chat with rich well um I don't know like
they like within that I can do a
dissertation on on the twelve steps and
the origins of the twelve steps it's a
superb but progressive modern college
you know sort of varies what I was
saying like in four bite like Foucault
Edwin Sayid all that kind of modern
universe is what it is and I want to
learn about the origins I want to become
wise well certainly yeah they're all
they're all of the ideas the core
principles are rooted in you know
ancient principles that date back to you
know it's finding the antecedent of that
would be super interesting and it begs
the question of just how divinely
inspired it was for you know Bill and
Bob to kind of channel this information
and you know put it on paper like where
did it come from for them like they they
were not they were not you know in they
were not religious scholars and yet they
were able to grasp these ideas and
translate them for a modern population
from the right ends that are available
to us within within fellowships it like
Bill Wilson describes an epiphany like a
very sort of plain flash of like kind of
immediate download which if you heard it
in a yogic tradition you've got my god
that's like the touch of what I've got
some funderbolt flash of God
consciousness and it also like so came
through but when you when I break down
the 12 steps it's essentially a tool for
awakening even in its own terms having
had a spiritual awakening as the result
of these steps so it's a feel
the way I've come to regard it is the
problem substance misuse is a carapace a
holding pattern for you know even within
the cotton finer the steps the defects
of character but you've come across step
six my last my pride my self-pity my
self centered their selfishness
intolerance etc and the only way I read
something today the only I think from
Yogananda the only way to over cut you
know we don't forgive anybody you
overcome the person that held grudges
like you know like myself can never
really forgive the self is made up a
locked into identification but if I can
transcend the person that feels
resentment if I can become another man
then those resentments are another
country well that that process of
iteration are you becoming another man
or are you becoming more of who you were
always meant to be or more of who you
truly are
I preferred your voice there yeah
recovery of the person that you were
meant to be someone said once and I like
that before we become impeded in
impaired and sort of tangled up and lost
in sort of the coordinates of a culture
that overly stimulates primal desires
and traps us in odd patents yeah so even
sober for a long time now at this point
right just eight sixteen years yeah yeah
yeah and and how is that how is your
perspective on your recovery kind of
changed over time like where are you at
with it now versus where you're at with
it at five years or ten years I take it
more seriously than ever I recognize how
fallible I am and I see that there is no
area of my life where I can't apply
those principles I try to spot as early
as I can where I am attaching to some
external idea and so I apply it
universally now whereas before it was
enough just not to drink and take drugs
I mean if I cannot drink and take drugs
that will be fantastic but I'm not
interested in addressing my behavior in
other areas what still yeah that's not
no consequences - yeah you know for
yourself anyway and so like it's it's
come very slowly for me you know I feel
like I have a certain mental facility in
some ways but was so spiritually um it
was not a flash of light source or so
but you're you've always been a seeker
yes you know and and perhaps that that
search for wholeness or for answers has
been pursued in unhealthy manners from
drugs and alcohol to sex relationships
and all the like but at at your core
you're somebody who's committed to
finding answers and filling that hole
and you know achieving connection and
wholeness I feel it's our natural state
to look for that kind of connection I
think that we were all looking for it in
one way or another and I suppose I must
have strong drives you know that's where
I see it now and I'm trying to see
though what those drives do if I don't
continually demand things of them if I
don't get me in a movie get me laid like
and if I just say what do you want to do
what happens what happens we have
someone in our Natasha you'd love this
because it's not anything he's out Hicks
was reading an advance copy but it's by
some one of them people who surnames Rin
posh like he's an Abba yah oh yeah
Tibetan Margaery Nepalese fellow and he
decided to go and wandering retreat and
like he was father gave him one bit he's
believed to be at Ulmer court on without
we know the reincarnated Lama or
whatever his father gave him one piece
of advice if you ever do this wandering
tradition tell no one so they eventually
he leaves his monastery sneaks out and
the dead of night and first like the way
he described like these anxiety in
getting into a taxi then he's irritation
being on a train with other people and
then he sent of attachment to his ropes
he says he says like my whole life I've
been trained in non-attachment like from
I learned language you know at the same
time as I learned nothing is real death
is coming
study these flowers everything's gonna
go don't get that you know and the gut
and the practice of it is entirely
different because he would like
necessarily
he became he was attached to non
attachment even - to his identity as a
prominent Abbot within a bloody
monastery so that makes me feel like oh
we can be forgiving ourselves of
ourselves those of us that have been
cultivated and grown to be egoic and
individualistic and materialistic and to
regard things as commodities what how
would we know how would we know well
that's the malaise that sits at the very
center of everything that ails us as a
culture you know socially and
politically this attachment to identity
are our egoic Center and individualism
at its core yes yes how are we gonna
overcome these and achieve this utopian
society of which you speak so fond well
my I reckon riches got to be this it's
got like its I believe it's through
service I believe that the way to
liberate myself from the belief that I
can only be happy if I get what I want
is to daily moment-to-moment remind
myself that I had like I wrote about it
in in loads of books I always mention it
nags away at me I when I was met Amma
one of the times I've had the privilege
of spending some time with Amma I went
to her ashram and after you get there
man tore off her in the hug one of her
this of Brahma and these more heavy
dudes ins of like robed up and pretty
serious not the Maverick shamanic man
you know sort of astray outta nowhere
person but this were inculcated and
educated brahmin one of them took me I
was in there get you go get the mantra
properly you get reminded of it in case
you didn't notice it in the giddy bliss
of the hug we're in some sort of garden
on the ashram and I looked at me and
watched him he was literally like a
butterfly out of his hand like it was
flying of my god this guy's so holy and
when he gave me the mantra he said to me
and the material world has got nothing
else to give you now Russell the
material world can only take from you he
made my stomach pull in like I said I
felt lower chakra tug of
I don't like resisting that yeah were
you able to hear it I did he read it my
body and
and it's only recently maybe five years
later laughs whoa no this is a blessing
because it means I don't need to go
through life in
people are gonna approve of me someone's
gonna give me fellatio someone's gonna
give me a pat on the back or an
automobile there's nothing there's
nothing to get and I have to continually
be reminded of it
almost relationship she's a relationship
exchange to exchange that there you are
not in this car to get something from
this driver you're not going on referral
podcast to get something from richer
like this is I have to continually but
that muscle of continuously continuous
practice is something you learn in
recovery through you know constant
surrender repeatedly throughout the day
minute by minute hour by hour at times
yes we're fortunate aren't we to have
learned it in the inlet of obnoxiously
obvious form of substance misuse and
al-qaeda bloody obvious and because we
we had to yeah and actually if we wanted
to reenter society what happened to you
it was I was pretty much a purist with
alcohol I was too afraid of drugs
because I knew it would be just way too
enticing but booze took me down and you
know my story is not the craziest story
of all time it's not super rock and roll
but it was dark and pathetic and sad
there was nothing sexy or romantic about
it you know at the end I was drinking
you know I would I would drink in the
morning vodka tonics in the shower I was
working as a lawyer I was sneaking
drinks throughout the day and just you
know biding time till I could leave and
go into a blackout and wake up in
strange compromising situations
wondering where my car is and what
happened and you know the police got
involved and there was you know judges
and jails and things like that to
contend with and family fleeing for the
hills until you know I basically you
know came to that realization that if I
wanted to live I was gonna have to get
sober and I went to a rehab in Oregon
for a hundred days so you were in you
were in treatment for like three months
right so you know like that's a that's a
longer more extended stay than the usual
kind of 28 or 21 day spin cycle in the
UK I think it's standard oh is it Russia
B yeah although it's not easy to get
treatment for
now you know then getting harder and
harder yeah I went to excuse me a place
called focus 12 sadly now closed down
due to a lack of funding which was a
twelve-step her treatments and it wasn't
residential in there so I had to throw
in a bed and breakfast run buddies
phenomenal atheist man chip summers who
was my first mentor in the program and
like I went there as a sort of ancillary
I didn't see this is like a watershed
transitional moment I just thought I'll
do this and then I'll get on with my
plan to become successful get people off
your back yeah that's right that's what
I was doing like so I remember I heard
someone say recently we should remember
that you know that when people are not
enthusiastic early in their recovery try
to remember how we were like right
because I knew now now that I've become
a zealous kind of a man I kind of expect
it would be very devoted and dedicated
in them so irritating listen what's
wrong with you I'm speaking to someone
today I was a person I care about a lot
that's actually as far as I know not
using at the moment but she is a person
that if she does not walk the line she's
[ __ ] you know like in the situation
she gets in it's almost like that I
sometimes feel it's sort of karmically
you know there are certain sort of
celebrities and famous people but the
problems that come in their life seem
sort of kind of low-rent trashy problems
you think it's almost like it's almost
as if your karmic essential self has not
acknowledged how could it you have now
ascended to some sort of privileged
position like you know tonight in my
country with like footballers or
whatever people from regular sort of
blue color I guess backgrounds but the
kind of issues they get in is as if it's
somehow ordained like you know the sort
of the mess of it all well you know yeah
when people won't listen I think what is
it what are you resisting what you fight
him but I only have to look at myself
and the film I resist and fight yeah
gonna holding on to that your best
friend until it's you know pride from
your dying clutch of course you know
it's not easy well you talk about
and you talk about Alma in in the new
book mentors which I enjoyed very much
you're a brilliant writer it's it's
fantastic and it was that book is
different than what I was expecting I
thought it was even given the title I
was sort of thinking this is gonna be a
more straightforward kind of self helpy
kind of thing but it's really a
narrative that unfolds in an
autobiographical sense in which you
weave in these people that I've had
profound impacts on your life at various
stages yes any way that I know how to
write prose as it turns out is I which I
think it comes from comedy is that if
you if I stray too far from authentic
personal experience I feel that I'm not
in territory that I know well so even
when writing about armor or like Bruce
Lloyd a therapist that arrived I know
Jimmy Marvel a mentor of mine or like
Emma as you have said all of the man
that teaches me BJJ critically I still
have to use it on how how do these
influences work on my neuroses now do
you know that filmmaker that is called
Adam Curtis he's a British filmmaker
you'll love his stuff if you've not seen
it he like makes it he'd start with
century of the self in which he talks
about how the the the insights of Freud
were used to establish the profession of
marketing and PR century of the self
you'll love that bit like on the war in
Afghanistan it's kind of sort of a
postmodern Baudrillard sore take on
those kind of the way that narratives
appear and a kind of I don't know
disingenuous and used to manipulate pays
a brilliant a very sort of pop in a way
who takes on hard subjects but he's very
pop he said that we live in our heads
and light so he said that my he says
that my right he was kind enough so that
my writing style is beneficial rather
than relentlessly solipsistic and like
we live now continually in the narrative
of our mind they're sort of like those
are endlessly spiralling dialogue what
now what do I do
now I'm gonna get laughs no there's no
so late and he says like to hear that he
said like a bulb Zach or Dickens like a
century or so ago they're describing
geography and phenomena now he goes
everyone lives here in their head in
their thoughts you know so like when I
also Eve it was so for me the journey
I'm continually trying to make is though
there's a macro journey of how can how
can the unenlightened man become
enlightened and then how do i moment to
moment when i'm when i reengaged if i
want this i want these people to approve
of me i want that happen how do i get
back you know if i'm startled or so
suddenly fearful or suddenly full of
desire how do i transition back to it so
I'm continually dealing with that voice
yeah well it's the hero's journey and
there's something about your innate
humanity and and and your willingness to
be vulnerable in the storytelling
matched with like this facility from
language that you have that makes it
very compelling and then you'll
surprisingly kind of zing people every
once in a while with you know a
paragraph about like here's how you can
do this - but it's done in such a way
where you don't really feel like you're
being preached to in any way because
you're caught up in the storytelling
itself and thank you in the humanity of
it because I don't like being told what
to do I've never liked it who does and
yet there is a whole massive industry
built around these books that are
telling people what to do and people
love reading them and buying them I wish
but I question whether they're effective
I think I think people read these books
a very small percentage of them take
that wisdom and put it into action but I
think a lot of people just feel good
about buying them and maybe feel a
little bit better about reading them and
and then it becomes this sort of placebo
that you might be right except acebos
can be sometimes correct yeah I mean but
like you see you've made a transition in
your life and it's [ __ ] hard isn't it
yeah go right I'm not gonna be I'm going
to be fit I am going to could put myself
through physical trauma or stress yeah
and so when somebody comes to you and
says Russell tell me how you know you
did this or how do I go from here to
there
and and what they want is a distilled
you know six point plan that they can
execute on and life doesn't work that
way and it's through the storytelling
the humanity that we can connect with
something that can live within us that
has staying power that resonates that we
will remember a year or five or ten
years later mmm yeah I think yes no I
agree with that I believe that but how
to frame it again within the 12 steps
which is how I I you know again lucky is
robust I feel like it works but that if
I'm if I surrender
okay that's the first thing if I go
alright I do want to change I do not
want to have this body I didn't want to
have this pure but you know and I have
these feelings about my partner I don't
to feel like I'm an inadequate father
and once I recognize once I come to that
point of I've got problem in my life son
manageable there am I ready just come to
believe that it can be restored to
sanity that is possible I like the
optimism of the program of the program
assumes that it's possible to be happy
not like it's not a some sort prata
stand we are born to suffer suffering
this good work hard flajolet you know
because i feel that you know that i can
see how that idea enters because the
death of self the death of the
individual the flagellation the
mortification of the flesh the loss of
the individual does sound a lot like you
know or at a self apart but I like the
Bliss of Hinduism I like the Bliss of
the Vedas I like the love the
voluptuousness the senses I don't want
to become passionless I don't think I
don't you know when I'm me I like you
know you meet in life people sometimes I
like the mischievous black dudes that
are on your wall back in your house you
know why because when they move or that
or the the the self-proclaimed
enlightened person that just hugs you a
little bit too long a bit too much
daring and yes more to this than staring
and Hawking staring and hockey no part
of it you can wake the repo nauseous to
take it out into the world right and
actually [ __ ] with it that's what's
good about that particular book is the
way that he's saying oh my god I've been
preparing for this my whole life now I'm
on this train I'm like these people
[ __ ] stink hey guys I have to remind
myself yes amateur come on
if you can't work on a train how you're
gonna work it on the next plane but like
he's saying you know I have there
amongst if these people have got a
bought birth and a death but they've the
Sabres be like how did that these
principles are challenged in the
material world that's why I think we
need that fundamental spiritual belief
that this we need to somehow have the
faith to have the commitment this is not
real this is not real and you can see
how people you know how that became the
kind of illness or Kreuk reduce
secularized cribs Christian cultures all
right you're heaven the afterlife so the
the billionaires can get on with being
rich and we just scuttle about in the
rubble no no no it's so that someone
said to me in like a one of them like I
met with a group in New Orleans and this
man went to me like he was off to he
looked he was such a romantic fellow so
beer didn't stained sure and some sort
of naval looking hat and heavy and
leathery and he went to me lady was off
to help the homeless and we were in New
Orleans so there was no shortage and he
goes it goes the material world this he
says this is this is just crumbs
don't settle for crumbs I want to be at
the banquet to recognize that anything
that occurs within this limited
bandwidth whether it's a source of
Lamborghinis or limitless orgies it's
nothing it's taking place on a pinhead
you know but they don't have access to
some kaleidoscopic experience but does
take discipline the Maya your bloody
thing it's gorgeous isn't it it is
gorgeous a little circuiting you know
delicious tasting lie I I agree with you
with the optimism of the steps but I
also appreciate the matter-of-fact
nature of them it's like you know the
the you will have a spiritual awakening
as a result of these steps not like you
might or you know it's possible but like
just do these things and you will have
this transformation and it doesn't
matter how you feel about it or how much
you're questioning it and the expansion
occurs because look recovery is littered
with people that coming you came in as
an atheist and now you're this like you
know you're ready to start your own
religion basically with the occult the
acolytes are you know everywhere at this
point no I just need to get the right
kind of blanket work on that stare
yeah and loan cattle and this is uh this
is very good for your ego I would
imagine oh yeah go for the irony yeah
yeah irony how are you how do you you
know sort of think about who you are and
what you do now like you're doing all
these things you're you're you know you
stand up these live performances these
like one-man shows you're here in town
because you're you're doing ballers
right like you're acting in this TV show
you've got books and you're kind of you
know this this sort of person of wisdom
at large right on social media how do
you balance all of those things and and
think about like the choices that you
have to make to kind of move forward in
this bearing in mind this this
commitment to being not attached to
results and the feeding of the ego only
discipline I try not to live in
abstraction I try not to look at I try
not to have famous in abstraction and
famous like someone else's conception of
me so I try not to be involved with it
because not again because of because I'm
too greedy if I start looking at it then
they always leads me somewhere bad
looking at the comment always leads me
somewhere bad caring and comparing
myself to other people always leads me
somewhere bad I'm living in Los Angeles
I don't have to look very far to see
people that are more successful more
famous bear looking nicer abdominal
muscles and they were generally more
unhappy well I I wonder I wonder so like
how I with a degree of immediacy whether
that's trying to live in the moment by
listening or whether it's like you know
like I can't believe how fundamentally
bloody transformative having a family
was I mean I suppose I should have
preempted a exist and of obviously in a
way but like having those you know
having my wife and daughters in my life
has necessarily made me present present
and like did it matter what's going on I
don't spend so much time looking at
abstract things or trying to nurture
yourself from the outside in some sort
of the definitely plainly illusory thing
like what someone says on your phone you
know like like stay here with them look
at them listen to them and when I'm able
to do it and I have no wrong so I
look rich I always feel slightly
fraudulent because busy stuff I'm doing
right now I'm doing it right now I'm not
like I don't feel any different from
when I was a little kid that's why I
believe in that recovery ideal I think
we're all born with that attacker with
that connection to a degree of mmm
purity or at least oneness perhaps one
this is a better term but like you know
I am sometimes holding a beautiful
little baby I'm thinking [ __ ] what
football you may need my phone wants me
and I want phone so how I well how I do
it is by like letting go like by not I
don't trust anymore the things that I
used to warn like various form I'm not
gonna allow myself to repackage egoic
adulation in some other format I really
like you know I always keep pursuing
these these these avenues that they're
just rife right up for that right
excited to tackle the yeah how about
starting a religion or becoming this
girl I mean there is you know of
anything that you could enter into like
this is feeding that monster that wasn't
caution you know awfully tackle this
tendency I've had toward egotism by
setting myself up sort of online digital
Jesus once and for all I slip it in
there but you should see the way I drift
around on my live shows or semi in tears
like looking at people lovingly out
reaching man they follow you down
Melrose I'm a comedian oh my god I'm a
comedian so like I know how it's all
ridiculous it's already it's funny to me
it's funny to me and that is I suppose
if I can bring anything to this world
into this conversation by this world I
mean this idea but none of us are ever
going to be fulfilled by trying to
augment our identities and acquire
material and Status attainment through
one another like the thing I think I can
contribute is by being sincere but funny
by by continuing to acknowledge this is
ridiculous this is to me this is
happening in limitless space then take
it too seriously like you know that's
what the thing that I'm trying to stay
focused on because you know lucky in a
world where we've got Eckhart Tolle
we've got Tony Robbins with all these
people that I saw
profound powerful communicators and know
how to do this stuff and I think well
there's no that you know all it like any
of us I suppose if we are authentic and
true to ourselves then it's gonna get
taken care of
mm-hmm yeah well I would consider you
one of those powerful communicators I
mean as I said earlier like you have
this facility for for language and this
ability to you know create a narrative
and argue your point of view in in a in
a pretty remarkable way but when I hear
you I often wonder I think this is so
easily this can be easily used not just
as a weapon but also as a shield like as
a mask you know I can hide behind this
facility that I have and keep myself
safe you might be right I mean I have
always done that
here are some other methods though that
I've got um like I don't look at porn
I don't objectify people I'm only I'm in
a monogamous relationship I know I can't
anything by cheat in people I mean in
the sense of like trying to get
something like these again it's the
program I'm running everything through a
program I'm running everything like you
know anytime that I feel a spike in my
energy fear or desire that destabilizes
me you know in a stepped in anytime we
are disturbed anytime i disturb i'm
checking it with other people so even if
i did start a cult it would be a good
one because i wouldn't be sleeping with
anybody I mean then comes will go wrong
when I come up with a system where I
have six everyone know and that wasn't
in the original brochure are you sure
yeah no it's good it's spiritual there's
some corollary to the rule that you'll
have to come up with I mean most of all
I think that's why people like in
positions of spiritual authority are
celibate because these are powerful
powerful energies I got friends that are
like a Swami's and like a hug men and
shake hands with females because it's
these are powerful force these are the
forces that carried our material form
here their desire to procreate the
desire to have space these energies are
bigger than individuals but they're
little saw what's that beautiful analogy
thinking that the egoic self is in
charge of the whole self is like a
stowaway on a crew
these biological energy is released
forces this stardust stuff thrusting and
[ __ ] me just floating around in there
like a little gorgeous Pippin so let's
not take that guy too seriously
as long as I shut down the avenues that
I know that he would explore like can I
have a golden throne and all of those
sort of things in the Bikram sort of way
is that what yeah Vikram
he had a big like golden throne that he
would sit on at that I'm gonna head
legitimately have a golden throne his
fleet of Rolls Royces but it all started
good just like everything right yeah oh
you know or back on as he was then I
always you want start series or another
yeah I was incredible how do you mean
isn't wonderful incrementally the place
you can get to right peace and love
we're all one all democratic people are
free to be who they are sexually we're
not going to inhibit anyone's identity
and we're gonna come to munch with
poison in a salad bar I know because I
[ __ ] human but if you shift that
aperture over to politics you can make
the same argument if you look at whether
it's you know Paul Ryan or Barr whoever
these people are like what were they
like his children what initially
motivated them to go into politics I
would imagine all of them had some
service minded you know aspect yes that
got corrupted by you know the egoic
beast that takes over and suddenly they
find themselves saying things that they
know in their heart of hearts they don't
actually believe and millions of people
are impacted yes rich and also
bureaucratic and administrative systems
shouldn't be in here dwith power it's
just for organization I feel that these
systems necessarily have to be curtailed
you know that their principal that you
know our leaders are trusted servants
they do not govern like you know like
their very simple principles would like
these systems can never be used to bring
about more equality they will always
sustained themselves I don't pay too
much attention and perhaps I should to
the particular individuals that are
occupying positions of power one because
of a conversation over if that Yanis for
a Farkas who ran through it so he said
that once they only won that election in
Greece they said we're not repaying that
day
it's all been a swindle yeah groove you
you know what's that effect I'm
paraphrasing but when they had the
meetings with the EU they really said
that he recognized that even I think is
cool about Wolfgang shell by a common
problem but that the German Finance
Minister he said that man only has the
power that that role affords him he has
like so that individuals power is
irrelevant the system is a
self-sustaining thing the people that
are seen the persons in the role of
President or Chancellor or Prime
Minister regardless of the particular
inflection of their political
affiliations there are sisters systemic
restrictions mean that no meaningful
change can occur and a meaningful change
can occur their primary relationships
with economic interests that exist above
the level of democracy we all know that
that's why there's a rising populism at
the moment which is being ludicrously
and ironically ridden primarily by the
riot which will further
fortify those interests so but populism
in itself I don't think is a bad thing
people becoming popularly interested in
politics people thinking I can't get
involved in this people really the more
people have direct control over the
things that impact their lives they're
better kind of anarchism couldn't
communities governed and controlled by
the people that live within them schools
government controlled by the people that
use in hospitals government control
alone this is of course it needs to be
some I suppose it needs to be some kind
of centrist systems people tell me
armies roads police forces etc but I
feel that the principle should be
minimized decentralized community
oriented populist I think so utopian do
you do you think here's what I'm curious
about because I've listened to you talk
about this stuff quite a bit and and
there's so much truth and wisdom and so
many of these things that you say and
yet I find myself saying yeah but that's
that's not gonna happen is that my
pessimism is this reality and how much
of this do you actually believe in terms
of its possibility and evolution or are
you holding this line way out on the
edge so that we can have these
conversations and open up you know the
possibility to just even begin to
entertain them Joseph Campbell said
nothing's ever changed he said you know
like the great master of
comparing myths and look you know that
power preserves itself leaders behave
our leaders behave um I do believe in it
because I feel that feudalism
transitioned to capitalism and that we
have not exhausted the possible models
for organizing systems and this is
another very simple basic tool and
perhaps these are the only ones I can
understand is when those of us that
think that the state of affairs is
lamentable and wrong and we would like
to change it look for a moment is that
are there any institutions or
individuals that would regard the system
as it currently stands as beneficial and
fortuitous yes well then that's why it's
like that it's not for therefore some
institutions and individuals it's not
problem that it is this way and I don't
believe in conspiracy in the sense of
internal Evelynn cabal's but I just feel
that there are sort of sustaining
systems and interests that won't be
broken unless there is a reasonable
opposition and that reasonable
opposition can only come from
I suppose organization rejection with
them do you have do you have a sense
that that we can change these systems
though at least in the u.s. yes I do
feel that I do feel that because I feel
like then you feel that with the current
political situation that there it that
there is a bit of a an anomaly you know
that's an odd thing that happened Trump
becoming president like that you know
sort of us I believe that but I also
think that's dangerous thinking and I
think that that that because thinking
that or professing that is to kind of
deny the perspective of so many people
that empowered him to take office I
would never be little or dismiss that
people that have reverted to nationally
F know nationalistic and patriotic and
patriarchy or even if not explicitly so
ideologies because what the grat light I
feel like that it's naive even to look
how can you divorce Trump from Obama
that was at one minute Obama was
president one minute later Trump was
president so there's an obvious
relationship and corollary and prior to
that these things are hot like they are
happening in relationship with one
another and the feelings of I feel this
all things that happen on the Material
Plane
are a reflection of subtler energies
that are taking place in the
consciousness and being of individuals
and these these energies become
systemized if enough people feel angry
and antagonized then they will respond
to beacons or that's what honest a
corroborate or retract that energy and i
understand why people are angry I
recognize why people are angry I think
it's they're not mad they're right the
neoliberalism abandoned the very people
that it was supposed to be protecting
the working-class people of the you know
because this is happening everybody much
is happening in America yeah they've
been looked over they have been unheard
and their lives have not improved their
the quality of their lives have declined
and there's a sense of desperation there
you know and that's gonna manifest in
you know all kinds of unpredictable
things that we're now seeing happening I
have great compassion for that but I
think it is you know yes the material
world is a reflection of our
consciousness and I feel like right now
we're in it a very interesting moment in
which where I look within my you know
admitted bubble I see a profound
expansion in awareness and consciousness
you know because I surround myself with
those kinds of people I suppose but also
I think even peering outside of that
because of look you know the internet
and social media there's a lot of
problems with that but it allows you
know these kinds of messages to
profligate in a way that they couldn't
before and I think we are seeing a lot
of people waking up to these kinds of
ideas the kind of ideas that you're
talking about at the same time there is
an equal if not stronger opposition
force it's like dark and light it is
joseph campbell like these are it's like
star wars that's happening
now and it's a race to the finish with
the the ticking clock meaning like the
environmental crisis that we're facing
at the moment yes the in fact that we
are individuals it's an attractive
argument because we really do seem like
we are individuals wrapped in bags of
skin it's hard to imagine that it is
perhaps more important and inverted
commas more true that we are one that
the consciousness that you experience in
the consciousness that experience and
the consciousness all of us in this room
our experiencing is the same phenomena
merely disrupted by its more superficial
what I say apparel like that we're the
same we are one only it's easy to tell
people you that your interests are most
important look after yourself look after
your most immediate family well this is
the Gestalt of modern Western society
does that mean the gets dull like this
this is the the momentum and like
everything is organized around that very
principle and there's a tremendous
amount of momentum behind it that's all
pushing us forward in a manner in which
we're not even consciously aware of it
and we certainly don't question it
there's some Native American activists I
think he might being called Russell made
or something I think he like ludicrously
actually was in last of the mohicans as
an actor and consultant but you agree
out there radical activist and he said
like you know there seems to be an
assumption from people on the left that
we the native people of this land should
form a natural affiliation with the
Marxists he goes but faith as he says
Marxism and capitalism these are
different sides of the same coin
both assume that the land is something
to be plundered both assumed and
industrialized and they're fun
post-industrial society both of us are
sort of both of those systems are
resource based so we look at things from
a very very narrow perspective even when
we consider ourselves to be considering
a broad gamut of political ideas it's a
very very narrow spatter spectrum in the
same way I would argue that our sensory
spectrum is narrow and limited but like
we know we're not going to start
questioning whether or not there are
different entities floating about and
fail or different vibrational
frequencies and forces communicate
of us continually we can't operate on
there so I'm sure we got get some dinner
we've got to get to bed we've gotta get
laid these are the things that seem most
important except it isn't working and it
won't work for people to elect
right-wing populist leaders we are like
CS Lewis brilliantly argues in his book
Mere Christianity that the the case for
God is not made externally through
theology but is made in our own belly
that we know when we've behaved badly we
know we were doing something wrong and
he denies that these are acculturated
the ideas that we've been talking don't
do that do as you will be done by
because he says there is no culture in
the world where pity goes there's
cultures where a man may take one wife
and cultures where a man may take five
wives but there is no culture where a
man is applauded for running away in
battle but there there is a sense of
good within us but we're so disconnected
from who we are when when your priority
is the pursuit of individual grandeur
and material accumulation and status at
that you know at the forsaking of
community and intimacy and connection
and you know service and all of these
ideas you become almost disassociated
with that belly that's telling you you
you have gone astray and so that signal
isn't even connecting yes that's right I
mean that is what's happened right so
that's the beauty and the blessing of
being a drug addict or an alcoholic
because you had this intervening force
that precipitated the crisis that
accelerated it and forced us to confront
it but I think most people are
experiencing a low-grade version of that
that they can ride out their entire life
without ever having to confront it
because they're scrolling and they're on
Netflix and they're doing whatever
they're [ __ ] thinking about your
promotion or the next car that they're
gonna yes yes I've done all of these
things today and I have to I've looked
at Netflix but what what you know so
what but what David Lynch I was talking
to you have his book yeah I talked to
him yesterday he very he's perspective
seems to me I wouldn't claim to speak on
behalf of David baby bloody Linda can
even leave himself
molnon and dry for the [ __ ] that guy
by the bins but like he instruct about
minds for me please
I just saw a finger like I can't
deconstructed with language I just look
at what these faith is doing and see if
I can write that on some level but like
he thinks just meditate just meditate
teach more people to meditate get people
meditating connect people spiritually
don't worry about the admin there so
trust with that yeah a track that you
will go that that that will then empower
somebody to go on their own journey and
then ultimately they'll be able to hear
that that's CS Lewis signal in their
belly yeah I think we got to do that I
mean I don't know that scene I like that
though I like the idea of give people
the resource of meditation give people
the resource of the 12 steps help it
like what is positive it seems to me in
cousin and now that I'm this face it
middle-aged that the younger people
appear to be Knology and and rejecting
the idea that they are but their primary
means for fulfillment is gonna be
economic and material it doesn't seems
like people are like that is a huge
seismic shift in our culture and I find
great comfort in that how that will play
out remains to be seen but it's super
interesting and it's something I haven't
seen in my whole life no like you'll kid
you've got some case I've been swimming
Superboy's the other twenty three and
what I know are they saying they're
amazing yeah and they're pursuing their
dreams their artists their you know look
they they have to meet their obligations
but they're certainly not you know
pursuing the dollar yes that's not
what's igniting their spirit yes I think
it's possible I think it's possible
you know we forget that this that in
this young country of yours just fifty
years ago there was so much social
unrest and disruption and of course the
systems that govern were able to
relocate that disruptive energy within
its accepted framework the we can do
what we want of the 60s becoming the I
can do what I want of the 80s but it's
such a short time ago is such a short
time ago it's the same with this 12-step
system only seventy eight years ago
different ideas are bleeding
into culture and even what we're doing
with these very these intellectual P
relations of our [ __ ] endless
podcasts we are giving people access to
ideas many concepts just so many on
there why don't we just like we're gonna
withhold podcasts for just a couple of
weeks give you some [ __ ] time to get
on and meditate do something valuable
yeah sorry go ahead
well I'm saying that the least so like
if I was 16 now obviously the my primary
use of the internet would be
masturbating but I'd like to think that
meets that I would be coming across
podcast where people are talking about
ideas they're just you know and I was a
school people talk about this kind of
stuff is like you as magic for free in
your hand you would have axed access to
all of these kinds of conversations and
how would that have shaped your thinking
and the decisions that you made as a
young person I mean I don't know I was
drunk and loaded the whole time so
probably not but for a lot of people you
know especially people who don't have
access to higher education
it's an incredible resource yes and I
don't think we really fully understand
just how dramatic this shift in how we
process information and receive it is
having on people I feel like what we
talked about about 5 min ago rich is
important because if there is some
limitless force expressing itself as
consciousness and that was preceded all
matter anything couldn't look after
itself have you ever heard like Terence
Mckenna talk very so it's like whatever
it is the you know you go the truth the
revolution it won't be tacky it won't be
phony
it won't be do drab like in it like it's
obvious like that this thing is we're
talking about great power great great
power that the you know that the sages
and the Rishi's are talking about that
Christ is talking about this is not some
flimsy little finger no will it be able
to go up against the Republican Party if
it can't if it doesn't have the priapism
and the virility and the power to
overcome that if it doesn't have the
power to reach people where they need to
be reached then it wasn't the truth
anyway so we don't need to concern
ourselves of autonomy we didn't need to
open ourselves to in my language God
allow God to come through and we'll be
laughing it goes back to what you were
saying about Shakespeare and the 12
steps the robustness of truth to Wistia
and the countervailing forces of
darkness yeah trust that we need not
worry because truth will prevail
due to its robust nature because cut
atom cuts again like he said like you
know that we use metaphors I'm thinking
me uncle and Foucault call this a pistol
around we're of so we use metaphors like
you know the metaphor that we were a bit
machine like came about in the time in
the Victorian age when in that of
industrialization he said the romantics
during the Romantic Age there the idea
was that nature is wild and crazy and
powerful and now we're all [ __ ] male
what we gonna do you know that mountains
that surround us now these are powerful
things powerful energies and I feel that
if we can attune to that if we can just
allow that you know this will make a
difference I'm not suggesting that we've
become somehow passive I imagine that it
will be kind of active I'm very
interested in the body and becoming
engaged in the buttocks it's something I
had left much too [ __ ] light and need
to learn about as a matter of fact yeah
well I want to talk to you a little bit
about that but I can't let that last
thing go I think that I think that that
uh we have plenty of room for four four
no not in a challenging way just to
elaborate on it I'm Jason Leslie we need
more awe and Wonder and I think
rationalism has left us deposited into
this space where we do look at those
mountains and we think well that's just
because these atoms have aggregated in a
certain way to create this thing and
there's an arrogance and hubris around
what we can know and what we do know to
the to say to the extent that we believe
that we're capable of knowing everything
and that everything can be reduced to an
algorithm or a physical law yes and my
experience defies that but to speak to
that publicly is to be maligned possibly
could be I suspect a physicist Brian Cox
who I really really like actually but
he's a you know he says he wouldn't
scrum self as an atheist but he didn't
think there's a God and he thinks that
everything can be understood rationally
so you know and I like him
I'm not I'm just using this as an
example I tried to say look when people
said the earth was flat they actually
fall here when people thought that the
summer around the earth they actually
fought it when like we keep discovering
more and more deeper and deeper and
deeper truths none of us it's very hard
to speculate or hold what these great
episteme Accor histo melodical shifts
will be we don't know what we don't know
when and it's so obvious to me that as
there are limitations to what we can see
in here because of the limits of the
instruments through which we receive
that information that the limits of the
instruments of receiving information are
not the limits of the information if
space is infinite knowledge is infinite
wisdom is infinite beingness itself is
infinite so how I suppose that pertains
to the way that man organized is the man
organized their systems mankind organize
their systems is well what seems to be
prevailing what is universal what is
perennial and what the occur occurs
throughout our philosophies love
kindness unity to given us oneness these
things lo these things must find their
way into the way we organize society and
when it's the opposite of that [ __ ] you
survival of the fittest and mangling of
that idea because it came around you
know that because Darwinism occurred at
the same time as economic and the
technological ideas that it was
convenient to sort focus on the idea
that things would take care of
themselves don't where if people are
starving in the gutter is some sort of
some force some organizing force is
taking care of that yeah well of course
the information is infinite our ability
to perceive and comprehend it is not and
the hubris comes in with this sense that
we we we are equipped with all the
facilities to understand everything and
yet we're just you know one millimeter
more evolved from the ape you know and
whatever preceded that right which are
incapable of understanding things that
we can so you know why not consider the
possibility that without some extra
frontal lobe on our brain that there's
all kinds of things happening then right
in this room that would fundamentally
change how we see everything and yet
we're incapable
fathoming it yes this seems correct to
me and that rare rationalism it bloody
good to understand engineering good to
understand material good to understand
science to organize things but to allow
it to become the preeminent
philosophical perspective is dangerous
because it excludes the unknowable and
the unknowable is almost everything so I
feel that and that's terrifying and
alright as well you know like sometimes
that you think of just to fall backwards
into death maybe there'll be some relief
in it to fall backwards to drown in it
to drown in there the kinds of vibrant
nothingness I don't know no no I'm
scared
nothingness well let's talk about the
body stuff so you finally you finally
made this leap to veganism lots of
people were waiting for you to do that
it's been a long time it's been a long
time coming cuz that's what happened
[ __ ] documentary that you're in
actually I watched that Kip Anderson's
bloody what the hell what the hell yeah
unlike itself chimed so neatly with my
belief about how the world operates off
of our [ __ ] it because like I've always
loved animals you know and I've always
cared to a degree about my health but
when added so that was oh my god is a
ruse this kook eruption behind this then
just hit your button you were primed for
that right yes ready for that is that
Rogan having tried to talk you out of it
he said that didn't he that there was a
lot of it so and of course this counter
arguments or whatever but I don't see
some powerful vegan lobbying forces like
around Washington right that was the
fallacy in his argument I mean the
powerful broccoli Lobby that once yeah
yeah that's not what's going on no I
mean look if you wanna if you want up
you know poke holes you're gonna always
be able to find some study that's gonna
allow you to poke holes but I think
there's a lot of wisdom in that movie
and I'm glad that it compelled you yes
yeah and I think it's consistent with
your spiritual principles I would
imagine that there's a lightness and
you know a sense of alignment that comes
with that
yeah it's made me feel I think I like I
feel healthier it's also making me I am
a person that needs to bring
consciousness to everything because
otherwise I'd go unconscious so it's
very good to know Beatrice khojali it's
very good to have to consider what
you're putting in your mouth because of
Reimer I wouldn't think twice straight
in there but my eleven month old
daughter oral everything straight in the
road is narrower though it's like this
thing like the vegan revs narrower well
it just life dude
as somebody who's you know on the
recovery path it's sort of an adage that
gets thrown around and it's so true it's
like oh I got to give up drugs I can't
like you know I can't [ __ ] around
anymore oh I can't gamble
I can't net what I can t eat like what I
want to eat any it's like it just
consistently gets narrower and narrower
and narrower but my experience is that
expansion comes with the letting go and
I've learned to not be afraid of those
things and you know on paper it looks
like your life is becoming more
restrictive and curtailed and restrained
but the emotional mental spiritual
experience of that is quite the opposite
yes we've been taught that freedom is
freedom to pursue our desires but true
freedom is freedom from our desires the
desires is not like this do that we're
not because we're an additive Society
it's all about adding adding
accumulating
yes but the piece comes with the
removing I wonder how we will cope when
sacrifice becomes part of it did you see
that Malcolm Gladwell wrote about that
when the civil rights movement was
formed around tight bonds that people
were when than people in universities in
the South were coming together like
demand equality or wherever these
relationships were strong people were
occupying buildings together movements
that take place you know invisibly
across sort of telecommunications
networks are unlikely to be as tight
initially I suppose that we do that that
suggests that we do need to communicate
directly that we need to see each
other's eyes that we need to come
together if we're
going to bring about meaningful change
that we're going to like again a lot
this is really influential thing I talk
about all the time where prior to Indian
independence Gandhi said what's the
point of us getting rid of the British
if we just replicate the systems that
they use it's just us doing it and that
that is what happened he said the India
is a country of seventy thousand
villages all of these villages should be
fully autonomous exempted matters
affecting other villages you know we
should be here lab built on crafts and
trade because we have to get let go of
our comforts we're obsessed with comfort
and gadgetry he said in the boys you
know love them what would he have made
of the phones knows it like so and it's
very hard to convince it but like I'm
happier when I'm not continually
checking the phone I'm happier when I'm
not obsessing when I'm not placing like
look the ultimate destination point is
clear it's written in probably 9th in
the books on your table is you the whole
self has to go as well you know that's
when it ends is when you've let go of
the belief that you're even an
individual person and that connection
with other human beings provides the
answers that you've been seeking your
whole life through other avenues then
you've been taught are the answer and
turn out to be these false prophets and
two years and two rationally underwrite
that because it would seem because
they're in relationship with other
people that is the verification of
oneness if I put your happiness above my
happiness is like I am on some practical
level recognizing why is why is the
concept of oneness so difficult why
can't we be like bees and have this hive
mentality where we just fully understand
the universality of our conscious
experience I think too much no
sensuality haven't we yeah senses are
very seductive I remember when I was a
very sensual person it was all I did
wanted to do all day long and I still
liked it I still I like pleasure and
that little bit of cheese your wife give
me but like whenever like when I taste
it it's like oh good this is gonna have
to think of some wire to be nice oh yes
I don't actually like this I'm gonna eat
all this push this into my ears and my
[ __ ]
thing never end no limits
so why why I'm sorry about what I did to
become more fit and have for this body
well you're doing a mean and strong what
do you do you look around though time is
run all the time run ride my bike swim I
don't know I don't do Brazilian Jujitsu
though that would just destroy me well
maybe I should maybe I should try I
would not be good at that I don't think
why why wouldn't you I anything that
involves coordination I can I can like
run but you know it's tough but you feel
good on the vegan diet
I feel good on yeah I've been doing the
BJJ I want to say this to you like yeah
do the BJJ I love him but when I like um
I love it I'm not good at it you know
I'm learning I'm no I don't tell myself
negative things little Russell needs
encouragement and love I'm learning I'm
learning um I like today went out like
my wife was putting a new car seat in
the car was the one that's in there no
no no it's not comfortable know that
two-year-old she's got she's got some
specific tastes I thought I'm gonna say
to each rolls how sometimes how detached
I feel from my body my wife he's active
she is of the earth she knows how to be
she knows how to do things thank [ __ ] it
was I'm like some gaseous little poet
just floating around at commentating you
know where she picks up that car seat
she gets it now if you leave me to put a
car seat in top the top tether strap
into the buckle loop I look to it but
that's not how you're wired
you know she grounds you but you can you
know show the vision yeah exactly like
you need both of that right yeah we know
you bet you met Julie you can see
there's a similar kind of like yin-yang
dynamic yeah what is it with you guys I
mean I'm much more grounded in practical
and rational and she you know she's you
know an ethereal being right you know
and she allows me to expand my my not
only my perspective but my sense of
what's possible she'll say why don't you
look at it from this perspective and
something I never would have thought of
and a sense of belief like a support and
a belief in a different reality that she
held for us we've been together for a
very long time yeah we've gone through a
lot and when we met we were living
completely different lives but she held
this
that I could not have seen myself so you
and you and you I think you I would
imagine I'm projecting completely but
that you fulfill that role in your own
relationship yes same actually I mean in
the sense of a vision as in imagining
and dreaming new spaces yes but it was
my wife we met when like in herself 11
12 years ago and she knew that we were
meant to be together and I knew I had to
try and set world records for
promiscuity how did you how did you
overcome that like did you just
acquiesce over time or what was that
process like for you actually wasn't the
promiscuity ultimately that was
problematic but it was more difficult
co-dependent relationships with
inappropriate partners like in my case
just people that I wasn't like I was
very attracted to there's a wonderful
Robert Johnson he's a Jungian analyst
who breaks down myths and uses them as
relationship tools he wrote one called
he one called she one call we and like
her he uses the Arthurian legend of
Kristen and his older to break down this
is a lovely bit of analysis actually but
the chivalric tradition of knights in
that was to that the knight would fight
for the honor of a woman and at least
that these tales are written in mythic
language when we translate them
literally that's why you know when
people talk about Disney thieriot staff
it seeps down in every aspect of our
culture and how we think about yes the
male and female is enough sin in a fairy
tale not suggesting in the Disney
version I don't know what objectives
they have over there and that crazy
castle but like in original fairy
stories their female is an aspect of
that with it well as in dreams as in
folk tales the individual the sovereign
the king is the you know the seat within
this self and they're like so in this
Tristan and there's old and Miffy bred
like he breaks down the chivalric
tradition when men were knights would
fight for the honor of the princess or
whatever knowing that they would never
be attained because there are some icon
of the divine and the unattainable we
somehow used that motif if for the
foundation of romantic love and like if
you look at sort of romantic or romantic
poetry romantic films so this yearning
this
earning that has no relationship to
praxis you have never let how are we
going to live this in the myth of
Tristan and this older there like he
then Tristan the night falls in love
with as older who he was meant to go and
fetch from an island for the king and as
old there is an ethereal magical
creature he came from an island you have
to get across the water to bring her
back and none of these people are actual
females or males their mythic archetypes
so like you know and he's in love of her
but he's not met you can't be with that
magical person but when he meets her
what's her name his older the white
hands if she's a sister of a kinsman if
he is these fighting you know but
alongside and she you know he talks
about in the myth that she's in the
furnace she's doing stuff with firewood
and that he can't be with her he can't
be earth because him we are looking
sometimes for the other person in our
relationship to be an emblem of the
divine and they are flawed fallible
people but sometimes you know initially
with that rush of early love is so
intoxicating isn't it wonderful when you
do when that you experience that you
know when I watching the film I felt
kata to be 16 18 20 whatever again and
to feel that delirium of all this
[ __ ] person they are God to me they
are good on me even better if they're
broken
oh yes then we can really get in really
destroy ourselves rollercoaster ride
well I after a few relationships like
that like after sort of exiting one I
felt like was to Jimmy a mentor said I'd
like Lee goes you can't keep doing that
next time you see the sign pointing in
the direction of their glamorous amazing
relationship maybe don't go that way
it's so hard though oh yeah I mean it's
so very alluring the flesh is alluring
and like in it that you know that we
don't good we are physical people with
nothing wrong with her you know unto
Caesar what is Caesar's and all that
there's nothing wrong with the bodies in
the world and but you'd knock down that
door enough time I mean you know you
know what that avails you yeah and when
I reconnected with my wife I felt like
oh my god I've been using totally the
wrong metric was it what do you mean
reconnected you had known her previous
yeah we known each other for 11 years we
went out when I was about
my early thirties and she was like 20
maybe she was even 19 but that sounds
worse isn't it but but anyway like so
then I was went off to pursue the record
and then like and you know when we got
back like we went on sort of one day and
on the first day is that also you and
she's like you know I'm ready to be a
parent yeah me too and that was you know
like from then on we sort of took it's
relatively slowly still but I think
that's only four years ago and we're
married and we've got two children and
I'm like I'm at peace I know like the
realness of it the earth Ness of it I'm
no longer looking to externally acquire
happiness so to what do you attribute
that shift the program the program the
bit Billy because I've known that that
could have happened at any point you
know as Nonna for 10 years but I just
wasn't ready to see that I wasn't ready
to let go of the belief that no no I've
you know I want to live this kind of
life I want to be this kind of person
and it's odd actually because there is a
real superficiality to that sort of
romantic and expressive and abundant
love in that when those relationship
ended I was quite abled for some well ok
because it was something about it there
was a construct it was taking place in
my consciousness primarily this
relationship was very very very deep
very EFT and real like this is a person
that I wouldn't want to be without you
know so and so I I'd not surrendered to
that before yeah and for years now yeah
yeah it's good it's a relief it's nice
to think that there is nothing like I do
it's nice to have practices I suppose
you know as far as the institution of
marriage and coupling and stuff
I suppose it works in that it's
beautiful to feel you know that idea of
like they're here I am here that's
seeing I but my little daughter says I
sit in my seat I sit in my seat I am
here I'm not over there I'm not looking
over there for something else there
isn't something
a magical thing no other agenda being
present and in it but also with enough
awareness and personal development to
understand that you know you're not
looking to this partner to complete you
and that's your own personal journey
that's your connection with your higher
power and your your you know spiritual
interior self and your relationship to
spirituality in general right that that
can't be solved through relationship
with another human being no no I think
that is the you know crux of of
suffering for a lot of people it's good
to have that it's good for to have some
principles of like you know so next time
I find myself going Laura will you do
this why didn't you do that I want this
like the tale that's that thing that's
never gonna work you're doing again and
every time I sell it to myself as year
but though this time I am actually right
really my relationship with other people
is an opportunity to be of service it's
not an opportunity to be served
that's yeah I have to maintain do you
have resistance to physical labor and
work to being in the body you know cuz
if you're doing all these [ __ ]
jumping around swimming cycling swimming
across things running like for you is
easy is it to go into that you don't
think of I can't be bothered
well there are late there are days that
I don't want to do it but but in general
it's it's my joy it's what I prefer to
do but that doesn't mean that I want to
go and dig ditches and do a bunch of
errands and all the other kind of
[ __ ] you know because for me those
pursuits like being in nature with your
you know just you and your breath and
your your heart beating in your chest
and the quietude is that's you know it's
not meditation but it is a spiritual
practice for me and yeah it's exercise
and all of that kind of thing it's
fitness but really it's a it's a it's a
means for me to more deeply connect with
who I am and to wrestle with those you
know age-old questions about identity
and purpose and connection and I finally
I find many answers through that
practice I remember as long as it's not
a replacement for recovery rowing proper
you know which is that's where I get
into trouble it can be part of step 11
it can be part of
contact but it can yeah yeah I agree
with you I agree with you so what you
have moments where you are sort of at
one you find yourself definitely and I
wouldn't say like some people say oh
that's my meditation like no it's not
meditation is meditation if that's a
very specific thing there are meditative
aspects to it you know you can call it
an active meditation but qualitatively
it's not meditation but it is a it is a
it's it's an it's a practice that's more
than just physical I would say yes yes
because at least lines just I think when
we are dharmically connected those lines
perhaps begin to disappear between
physical action implicit or all things
can become worship I agree with you that
meditation should be practiced sans
steel with your eyes shut because when
you say all my meditation is right
riding a bike or something or listening
watching the TV you know you're like
you're not being confronted with what it
is like to observe and let go of the
thinking mind correct no and it's a
return to the macro point of the way
that we organized societies perhaps that
happens but perhaps society is organized
in the manner that it is because not
enough people have a sense of the sacred
and divine
we're not cultivating that relationship
because those individuals we're not
having a meditative or transcendent
experience and no one nobody knows how
to practice these principles in all
their affairs no one knows how to live
that because they are only thinking yeah
that is certainly correct and I think
that goes hand-in-hand with kind of the
the the downfall of organized religion
and with all its problems there you know
was an aspect of that that was served
through those institutions that doesn't
exist to the extent that it once did and
so we have this vacuum it's very
interesting I I listen to a podcast just
last night with Ezra Klein who's a
political pundit and David Brooks you
know the political journalist David
Brooks is like a conservative journalist
and he was talking about it was
fascinating because he was
this very subject how he had become this
workaholic a very successful
well-regarded you know person in the
space of political journalism at the
very highest level and the vacuum in his
life that had created because he didn't
value connection and relationships
because he couldn't be bothered because
it was always inconvenient and he
couldn't rationalize the the time
investment that it required and the kind
of existential spiritual crisis that it
provoked in a most unlikely you know
character and this journey that he goes
on and he just wrote this book about it
and I just found it to be like it's one
thing for you and I to talk about these
sort of things but to have that you know
in the costuming of somebody that you
would not expect I think carries a
certain powerful resonance with it
because a guy like that is able to speak
to a certain sector of the population
that perhaps is disinterested in what
Russell Brand has to say that Paul so
yes the poor fools out there in the
wasteland in the wilderness of no
program no I agree with you that it is
appealing and attractive takers because
I suppose it verifies our sense of truth
to hear that someone that's devoted
themselves to conservative outlook a
political outlook and and and the
openness to I mean part of that
evolution was his ability to change his
mind you know which i think is we're in
an epidemic right now of being so
calcified around our ideas because they
threatened our identity and that's
something that you know must remain
unshakeable to entertain the alternative
is terrifying for a lot of people and I
think it keeps us stuck in these
conversations that are you know kind of
driving culture off a cliff in a certain
way because we can't have nuanced
dialogue don't you want to get people on
your podcasts that are like outrageous
folk you know I mean I sort of do and I
sort of don't I don't see how as people
go you share to you don't give them
oxygen because I sometimes nearly did
raiga scared I mean I think there is
it's it's like would you have Alex Jones
on your podcast
I saw you would like right-click see I
probably wouldn't cuz I understand sort
of add or something about Alex Jones but
there's something about him he's a
boolean he's gone wrong I kind of like
it like you know in like that one him on
Rogan at Tyler's I couldn't I got like a
half an hour into it and I couldn't I
couldn't finish it because it was so
bananas yeah because he's out there
isn't and I thought I've met Alex a
couple of times and I suppose I only
part company when this is the thing I'm
trying to do it's like that if you have
a spiritual life it is for you it's not
something that you would inflict a lot
of people like it your spiritual life is
his must be real life they shouldn't
[ __ ] each other how can I help you this
is what I'm gonna do to be okay with the
world there's only when people start to
get caught up in you know the impulse
the patriotism is merely a
reappropriation tribal impulse that's
inhered within human beings necessarily
for us to socialise that's being
reappropriation attached to abstract
ideas in order to control a population
and it gets to the point where people
aren't willing to see there is no
England there is no America there is no
France or blood completely [ __ ] made
up some people gay but you know like a
century ago you know young Americans and
young English people were being asked to
give their lives away so no wonder like
and now people are I don't want him
[ __ ] coming over here living here
spilling our jobs I've been generation
deep told that this is real kill for it
fight for it it's real it's definitely
not an abstract concept made-up resource
from the same principles of the religion
that we have believed that we've
progressed beyond believing in it like
as a template is identical Godhead an
inside group and an outside group no so
but how I like and I feel like you know
I don't know if I wouldn't like you know
I I think that there might be more value
or like eg I had Candice Owens on the
podcast and like and I found it to be
absolutely adorable that's it that was a
I listen to that and I found it
fascinating because I completely
disagree with almost everything
she's about and yet she was rather
delightful in that conversation with you
and you had kind of a really fun banter
and I think it is important to have
conversations you know with people that
you disagree with like this is the self
upon this wound
you have right now if we stay polarized
is the tension of it is not good
after the podcast finish there's a bit
where she went and shows what do you
think about immigration Russell when I
was like well you know I think we should
be inclusive yeah I know what you think
let's just let everybody in and that's
just march around and skip around again
she didn't even like she's being so self
parodic but I spoke to Henry Giroux and
Brad Evans they're much more kind of
brilliant post-structuralist
left-leaning philosophers and they were
like don't be seduced by the individual
charm of people because that's often
used there's a kind of lubricant that's
like you know wacky I mean they're very
they're very aware of it and this is
this is what scares me because you know
fundamentally like I'm a pathological
people pleaser my biggest goal is when
Russell leaves here I want him to like
me you know or I want my guests you know
what I mean the people I have to be like
yes well I navigate the world helping
out with this sweet HOD cast toast that
makes you right for manipulation you
know what I mean if you have a
charismatic person sitting across from
you who represents a point of view that
is something you disagree with it's very
easy for me to become you know swayed by
their personality character defect of
wanting to feel connected to another
human being I do you want to feel
connected to other human beings I do I
do but like I feel like that if people
like you can track it though rich in it
like you'd like a foothold on that's mad
that's great as soon as they start
saying these people shouldn't be allowed
to do that what if it happens an hour
later without realization right well you
gotta know how to trace are they saying
so racist yet but I mean you're right
they're so nice they brought cookies I
know I loved them like are they are
quite nice how about have you ever
I keep doing around this and probably
shinai sort of watch Steve Bannon on the
internet and do it an address
the Oxford Union because if alright this
is that Steve Bannon I've heard about
how bad is let's watch him on the Oxford
Union he can I mean it was he's almost
as a piece of theater you should watch
it he arrives in a rain spat Mac you can
hear the protesters in Oxford like like
Charlie came out here get him out of
there he's off comes in like sort of
gumshoe detective in it like it just he
goes and like he for a ban our he didn't
anything I disagree if he talks about
the financial crash the implications of
it the corruption the relations between
the financial industry and Washington he
doesn't at any point go and that's why
this group of people should be excluded
or these people when he doesn't talk
about religions or races or recommend or
a sex or a economic classes all in
today's elites and he's saying and any
said that one thing that I really agreed
with you know populism is the future all
that's being decided is whether it's
left-wing or right-wing populism and the
only thing that we're debating right now
like so and and I would challenge people
to watch that because obviously I watch
it were in the perspective of I don't
like instinctively I don't agree with
people that are condemning of other
people on the basis of some sort of
ethnic or external data because I think
people my deepest belief is people are
all the same but like so forth but for
me that challenge is a bit of a
progressive lefty type of person is to
be tolerant and willing to engage in
dialogue with people that are to look
for what is what is it that I agree with
you know the Donald Trump or Tony Tommy
Robinson in my country or well you know
what is he I agree with what is it that
I can share with them you know I feel
like I've not been bold enough to put
that into practice because I can't be
asked with the [ __ ] hex give them a
platform you're giving them oxygen well
yeah because everything is so heightened
right now the sort of social price that
you pay for taking that risk isn't worth
it for most people you know and I think
there's a chilling effect on that but it
is interesting that you as a you know
progressive liberal myself as well you
know social justice warrior you know to
entertain the ideas of Steve Bennett and
go maybe there's an idea there or two
that I should think about entertained
when I hear that I see somebody who has
you know kind of transcended this former
personality like the guy who was doing
the truths back in the day I probably
wouldn't have had
that kind of perspective but one of the
things you said at the outset here was
like I don't you know you're kind of
past getting caught up in the
vicissitudes of the daily political
discourse because these are systemic and
they're not based on you know we can't
get caught up in the personalities that
are driving them that option that's well
thanks that arch exponent of the neo
liberal experiment who along with
Clinton Bill Clinton and took it to the
point where with inverted commas
ordinary working people no longer feel
represented by a left-of-center politics
Tony Blair see it was one of his famous
Maxim's while still shadow home
secretary before you know elected to
government was tough on crime tough on
the causes of crime and I feel that you
can apply that tough on racism tough on
the causes of racism what's causing this
racism all these people feel
disenfranchised and that they're no
included in society how are we gonna
stop them from being racist well I
suppose they're gonna have to feel that
their life is meaningful and they're
incorporated up inconvenient I feel like
you know like I think when one of my
mates so I said um you can't cure height
with more hey he's always gotta be
lovely it's always gotta be you've got
to keep loving them I think that's a
beautiful place to stop I would like to
talk to you for like two more hours but
your publicist will assess now can I
promote these things I must oh my gosh
what happens is they come back and they
go you didn't promote those things do
you promote that book if I did and I
read it and I loved it I think you know
it's it's it's it's a short easy read
too short and easy what you don't want
to say he'll Mentors
I think it's uh I don't know I like what
you just said that's been promoted very
successfully now luminary is the other
thing because they're paying for the
publicist do Maneri so there is luminary
so you I am honor you've you've migrated
completely over to luminary now on the
24 yeah that's right if you sign up
through this link you can have under the
skin for free for another three months
but on the
premium content straw right of it so
free months three months for free and
and then after that it goes behind a
little bit yes five equate seeks quit
for those that don't know luminary is a
new company that sort of trying to be I
guess for a lack of a better phrase in
the Netflix of podcast names right I
think that's a good thing recruited a
number of high-profile folks like
yourself - yeah create for for them
they've given us money now what like
happen was is on my podcast yesterday
it's not been out yet but about Lena
Dunham who's just immensely lovely
lovely and cara cara mo out of queer
eyeing it caused them to don't live now
yeah that one's already out right is
there beaufort luminary that's why I
mentioned I mean Lena Dunham Quran mo I
think Trevor Noah
he ain't been on the show yet but what
I'm saying is is that I've now promoted
luminary and no wonder that isn't just
being promoted and I'm doing live shows
are you gonna I feel like I me and my
wife should come around your house but
that's not how invites work is it you
don't save me and my wife should come
around right now your I you're welcome
to come by cook for you would yeah
because I think like your wife I think
like it and what's the other thing I'm
doing these live shows yeah I came in
Los Angeles I think you would like them
and I think your wife would like do you
wanna wonder last soon right that's
right yeah when do with this podcast
feed live I don't know probably not for
a little bit though what do you do store
much keep these little go running across
a [ __ ] amount in all right hours find
God sneering at a crack in a rock I'm
saying everything's one back down from
the mountain cut it out right away
pointless June 9 mark in the retirement
people pleaser in me will have this up
by tonight oh they're interesting that
we've just spoke about nothing but God
and get rid of the material world back
geez is that at the end of the podcast
right now the material world is real go
out and buy this [ __ ] material right
now we should properly say what's up to
Stephen and David Flynn because they're
the ones that introduced here
so they're in that book uh I know I love
that they got a shout out shout out in
the book I was very taken with him what
I liked about them lads was I like I
have to learn I had a I like versions of
maleness that I feel like all that I can
role model them and they were very so
very male but so soft generous and sweet
and sort of loving but you know that's
but I very nearly will allow myself to
jump off of a button Peninsula because I
know I I know that I've jumped off of
you've been there I have of course is
that what you did with them when in
Ireland I've done a couple yeah I mean
I've spent a lot of time with those guys
the cynic in me did you find this like
the cynic in me is like they can't be
like this all the time like what's that
what's it like when I wasted dogs yeah I
want to see that me watch me mess but I
mean I don't think I think it's there I
think they have transcended the dark
side I didn't see any dot yes I was
studying them I couldn't even work out
like we went around me my wife and kids
we went around like this some house of
there seems like a farm and people that
would make them like this a little vegan
cheese yeah it was little big a nice Pig
so lovely and look he one of them
Stephen a think had his top off they way
I had their top off the whole time of
course the top of this is my wife rock
against about the car and he's like oh
job me to carry that baby and I thought
yeah he had that baby for so long too
long in my opinion maybe an hour and a
half of having a baby wasn't it have a
baby pressed against you too much baby
did he do handstands with the baby oh
man another thing that was [ __ ]
amazing is that done podcast with him
and this rather than that strong do you
remember I texted you and I was like I
can't believe you got them to sit still
for five minutes that was a challenge
and they weren't still immediately
before it ran not Swami is it down like
he's also mentioned in Romans but he's
holy
that's like disciple who's proper path
chosen you run the Harry Krishna
movement which let me to get in no
slouches them they've got some power
those dudes so like radhanath swami like
you see him he wanted people who make
you bit hot cuz of like he's lee no he's
staring there there's some serious
staring happening baby brilliant with
the bag of Akio he's switched on full-on
Swami when you go see him in India each
temple they're frying themselves these
feet you know like literally
prostrate on the floor like that for
while I'm lying down face down not kneel
before Zod as Zod suggested to Superman
but lay face down before sort of even
sub didn't ask for that so they were in
like I did the podcast back to back in a
life in you in opposite there join in
wherever that was in the west coast of
Ireland through stones grace those
before an amazing place and like there
so he lied to dumb them lads and then I
was crossing over and to doing Randolph
Smiley's that we were in the lack of
green room it's just some sort of ante
room means like this theatre venue right
and he was like rather Swami sat there
like in aqua ropes at all our prior
beaming shaved heads you know maybe even
some sort of chalk so he did have like
gonna short bindi type stuff Danny
worried and I'm like what's that on your
head and touching him and then like a
and then fingers would you like to see
me not your latest trick a monk before I
don't think you minute do well this is
there something she didn't beautifully
refreshing about that
yeah joyful they're absolutely terrific
beautiful lovely men yeah really likes
of a lot I tell another thing about the
Brazilian Jujitsu I'm doing everywhere
Ribeiro school being trained by
Professor Ricardo Wilkie got calling
professor and he's full of respect this
culture so like but the other day though
there was a teacher I don't know if he
was he was a little camp I don't know
how can I know what he sexuality was but
like you know there's a presumed
machismo around the world of martial
arts even though there's some other
loveliest people I've ever met most
Jennifer this guy that was teaching he
was a little bit camp also blew me away
to see someone go okay right so now we
do my phone again I said this man's your
new favorite BJJ teacher camp and then
tough I mean he's blown my mind rich
what a world
well an odd world of collision and
paradox welcome to Los Angeles
uh-huh
as where I am yeah I really liked it
there's so much to learn isn't there
hold on I'm it like what boy I want to
have some bit of information that's
gonna make me better exercise him
because I'm holding that car see I can't
find it in my CI care and blues not
doing it for you yeah it is
what about yoga I like I'm doing a lot
of hot yoga you don't get in do you not
as much as I should mrs. doesn't does
she do delight a bit yeah I do yoga yoga
come to me yeah like they say hey this
is a finger person told me like they in
Hindi the fray so you know you would say
I speak French right like in Hindi they
say Hindi comes to me in there beautiful
even the speaking of a language is
regarded not as something that you've
both that it's regarded is something
that flows through a limitless library
that is beautiful
how can I help you with your fitness
though well I think you want to go
running with me all right
he'll do that I'm scared right hold on I
got those shoes the team say these fast
no no you guys go
no no man speed at this life but I have
like I can go I go slow I just got all
our hovered in it depends depends on who
I'm with
here if we go we go we go we go however
you want to go all right my daughter
I'll take you out I'll take that x-ray
sounds like a lovely experience how long
will the run be going for as long as you
want it to
how long would it we bend time for hours
I'd like to lose myself in there yeah
all right I'll get you out there
extremely fit now I got my work cut out
for ya all right
your uh your publicist is gonna kill me
so we gonna let you go okay but I
appreciate it that's your heart out got
your heart out I was told you have a
heart out you know your baby before
traffic starts going that way don't get
home and babies oh I got you I haven't
got any jobs that's good I'm
unemployable yeah
there's no the rock isn't waiting for
you right now
the rock a way for Nolan that's going to
be eternity that that's gonna be a trip
working with that guy he's like a
pharaoh
yeah you've got like sort of he's got
chief energy he's why I'd say he's got
sort of the energy of a
King from a like a non-european culture
like literally like a benevolent
Scorpion King exactly it was really like
when I first met but he's really
beautiful and lots of kind and easy but
he said in that peninsular of Fame where
you're assured off in cars the whole
time today I mean there's always people
around you but like there's a this like
when I've done the first season of
ballers I made this mental choice don't
be an [ __ ]
subtle thing but it helps in a working
environment I'll do whatever people ask
me I said on that job I'm gonna not like
make things difficult
just be there be amenable and easy you
I'm dating like they think about this
job all is that a contrast from previous
work yes
I'm gonna use this job as a waiter for
corsets this work pretty easy to work
through my psychosis my feeling I'm not
good enough well I can dump my [ __ ] on
that guy over there if I'm really
unbearable so like I'm just gonna like
you know when I'm at work my primary
purpose is to do a good job at my work I
work for these people I've got a
contract these people don't if I'm
questioning what am i doing
am I being kind to the people around and
useful these are all things like to
thank you so long to learn so obvious
aren't they well anyway so I'm being I
think I wasn't know to any things they
asked me to do and like both the joy of
ballers if I may be so bold is that all
my scenes are things like Russell or the
character I play walked in a room says
some stuff leaves room it's never is on
a horse jumps have a Nilla copter
smashed in the face it's nothing like
that
and I thought this is gonna be a piece
of cake what a breeze of a job and then
like the wonderful director of the last
season this fellow Julian Farina English
fellow called me on day two ago so we
thought it was so wonderful living scene
on Malibu beach where when you're
talking to Dwayne and to rob corddry the
brilliant actor that does all this
things with Dwayne because if you like
at the end of the conversation take your
clothes off and walk naked into the sea
or Malibu beach not stating in front of
hundreds of extras I'm not yeah okay I
don't not go to my wife like you know I
said that thing I'm gonna say yes to
everything and I'm gonna be compliant
and easy to work with what do you think
shall I do she goes yeah just say yes
and I go yeah we'll do that so like that
means the next day I'm gonna have to do
I'm nervous about being naked in that
situation I get my wife a note before
take folk off of my ass
so I can see what my ass looks like now
here's the key thing if you're having if
you ever have to get your ass out you
don't have to worry if you've got no fat
on you but for normal people don't tense
it
you think tensing it is gonna beat you
up but never let dimples and wrinkles
relax the ass relax the artists Frankie
Goes to Hollywood used to say so like I
learned what was the optimum state for
my ass before doing it obviously windy
situations like there was a paparazzi
there and loads of extras and rock is a
exact on that show so cuz I'm bit
nervous about doing this Murr say in
front of all these people need was oh
yeah and he was like a benevolent king
and he went let me organize this for uni
organise all the extras to line up in
flanks facing away to form a human war
to stop paparazzi taking pictures of me
I had to walk into the sea with what is
called a [ __ ] sock over my yeah adaptive
organs all trussed up in there like that
very weird moment when you take off your
coat and you're naked and you know that
your ass is being looked at action and
then you walk it's a very strange
feeling you know and then it created so
if you don't you sometimes think that in
your life there's some weird glitch in
the matrix moment where everything goes
mad cuz in this moment I was doing that
I'm feeling all self-conscious and
walking away from the rock who's lost on
the list of men I want to be naked in
front or by the [ __ ] way
like heat like Gary Busey appeared he's
known in the show the little pale kid
what was his kid little kid was like the
mayor of toy town okay he's broken this
Gary Busey there's a car alarm going off
the rocks talking the Gary Busey Gary
Busey a distant did not look like Gary
Busey but a person who had fallen
through the cracks of society I know I
mean I see him around Malibu all the
time yes it was as prominent as a
feature like it's like a nose it was a
second nose okay that's the TV show I
want to see it was just the
orchestration around all of that is more
compelling about shows of TV shows is
that the infrastructure and the thing
that's not seen is you know yeah what's
but beyond the scene is so beautiful at
the point being that the rock marshaled
his copious
super powers to create his human wall to
protect you so if you have a trust and
his frail in his frailty yeah that's the
real message yes so now I have a
three-dimensional picture of this human
being all right all right now I'm gonna
let you go home
thank you my friend Mentors check it out
check out under the skin on luminary and
rusty Rockets all those kind of places
all right come back and talk to me again
[Music]